It used to be that when you were an author,
you hoped your book would hit the
New York Times bestseller list.
If it did, your book sales would skyrocket.
Traditional outlets like the New York
Times once wielded power and prestige.
They could influence everything from the books
you buy to the people you vote for, some say.
But the power of mainstream media is waning.
Although CNN saw a considerable spike
in viewership during the Capitol riots,
as it tends to do when there’s breaking news,
their audience numbers on most days are abysmal.
When CNN touted in this press release how
it beat out MSNBC in views in April 2022,
it ironically revealed that its
own numbers weren’t that great.
CNN’s flagship shows often bring in less than
200,000 daily views in the key 25-54 demographic.
Yet even their views online are often
less than those of independent YouTubers.
Why are powerful networks with millions
of dollars of backing behind them
getting fewer views than some
individual content creators?
I thought about my time working as a
television reporter, most recently in London.
A new day and a new prime
minister, good morning Anne-Marie.
I’ve compared that with my work now
as an online content creator.
There’s a massive
difference between videos made by TV
networks and videos that are made by YouTubers
even though both are video-oriented.
Online content creators have
a lot more creative freedom
which often makes for more compelling content.
I can make a six-minute video about
the difficulty of landing Starship
or a 23-minute video about the dark
web crime kingpin of Silk Road.
You don’t get the luxury of
that much time with television.
Take the example of interviews. You might
notice that the format of web-only interviews
is different from interviews made
for TV that are then released online.
When Joe Rogan speaks to guests for
his podcast, the conversation seems
natural and unscripted - and often
lasts between two to four hours.
Whereas TV interviews are time-sensitive
because they have to move on to another segment.
There has to be solidarity.
I have to end it there because
we're out of time. We'll be back.
As a result, interviews often sound like
soundbites or may appear inauthentic.
Even when TV feels authentic
you’re still restricted by time.
In this hilarious segment from Global News,
the Canadian network where I used to work,
one of the hosts made an artichoke
dip and  it went horribly wrong.
But there's no vinegar in there.
So here's what happened. What?!
This was fantastically entertaining
and could have gone on for longer but they had
to cut to a commercial break or another segment.
I’ve felt these time constraints myself. My
stories were only 1 minute and 30 seconds long
because so many stories have to be squeezed
into the nightly newscast, usually an hour long.
Time constraints hurt storytelling
becauseyou can’t delve deeply into a topic.
Shows such as 60 Minutes
offer longer-form reporting
but they don’t air daily because they
take considerable resources to produce.
When daily TV reports are later uploaded online,
their short, rigid format fails
to compel people to watch.
For example, my report about a zero-waste
grocery store in the UK may have gotten
hundreds of thousands of views when it aired
on television stations in North America,
yet it only received 600 views on YouTube
when uploaded by a local Chicago station.
Or take Bloomberg Technology’s YouTube
channel. They simply reupload segments
from their TV program online. The result
is just a few thousand views per video.
It’s hard for networks to produce content that
works well for online because their storytelling
is beholden to the format for television
and the advertising dollars it brings.
You’d be hardpressed to find a network willing
to do an in-depth review of the iPhone SE
like on MKBHD’s tech channel, or a 12-minute video
about why black balls are floating on a
reservoir like on Veritasium’s science
channel because TV audiences don’t have long
attention spans for that kind of storytelling.
So, why is it that when CNN focused on online
video by launching a streaming service,
it flopped?
CNN+ was touted as the Netflix of news.
CNN’s hired hundreds of people and created
dozens of news shows for this service.
It featured original series, documentaries,
news shows, and live daily programming.
Instead of the 2 million subscribers
that the head honchos at CNN anticipated
after a year, CNN+ reportedly drew
fewer than 10,000 views a day.
The service shut down in
April after just one month.
Pretty much no one wanted to pay $5.99
a month to watch news shows when they
can watch videos on YouTube for free.
Even Netflix is struggling to retain
subscribers partly because of price hikes.
And again, CNN+’s shows still
maintained the familiar format
of a TV broadcast which
doesn’t work well for the web.
Although the brains behind CNN+ felt it
stood out because of its interactive feature
where viewers could ask questions,
it really wasn’t anything unique.
Reddit has been doing that for nearly two decades.
CNN banked on its brand name to carry the day.
But it was a humiliating failure.
Traditional outlets used to be
the gatekeepers of information.
If you wanted to know what was going
on in the world, you got your news
from the radio, your local newspaper, or on TV.
Now - anybody can be a reporter.
Some argue this opens the door to disinformation
as professional journalists are
the ones trained to fact-check.
However, there are also accusations that
media outlets can’t be trusted, either.
This media bias chart created by the company
Ad Fontes Media shows the perceived
political leaning of various news outlets.
Instead of despairing about their demise, media
organizations have to reinvent their format
or face certain death when EVERYONE
cuts the cord which is inevitable.
Social media platforms have made it
possible for individuals to accumulate
millions of views - even without the backing
of a multi-million-dollar organization.
If you want to learn how to make videos like mine,
you don’t have to go to a fancy school or take
an expensive course. You can learn on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes.
There’s a great class with Ali
Abdaal on how to edit videos.
It’s great for both beginners and those who
want to brush up on what they already know.
Polymatter has amazing classes on how to make
great thumbnails which are super important.
You gotta get them to click before they watch.
And MKBHD walks you through the whole process from
start to finish of scripting, shooting, and editing.
There’s something for everyone,
and you can try Skillshare out for FREE
by going to my custom link in the
description and pinned comment.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom